the background to these offenses as
we've heard lies in violent criminal
gang rivalry between those connected to
the wood Church estate
and others connected to the Ford estate
on the world
you Chapman were very actively involved
in the wood Church gang whilst you
wearing were associated with it
the violence included shootings during
2021 and 2022
and created very substantial concern to
the people of merseyside
on the 23rd of December last year one of
your Associates was attacked by Jake
Duffy and Kieran salkeld in the street
they were part of the Ford estate gang
and when you learned of that you decided
on Revenge
in premeditated and carefully planned
murder of Jake Duffy and Kieran sulkeld
you use the stolen Mercedes A-Class car
with false registration plates which you
often use for your drug dealing
you disguised yourself with dark
clothing a mask a hood and gloves
you obtained a submachine gun and a
loaded magazine with 12 bullets
when you left your home on the
woodchurch estate to carry out the
shooting you took care to avoid security
cameras on neighboring properties
once you reached wallasey village where
you knew Jake Duffy and Kieran salkeld
were to be
you waited almost three hours carrying
out reconnaissance as you drove to six
different positions until you reached
the car park close to the front door of
the lighthouse where you hid inside your
stolen car waiting for your moment
and then at 11 52 shortly before
midnight when the lighthouse was full of
people and standing outside at the front
was the group of six
from a hidden position at the side of
the building you burst forward to be as
close as a few meters to fire the
submachine gun
Ellie Edwards was killed instantly
you hit five others with the bullets all
of them might easily have been killed
also
as you ran back to the car you fired the
last few shots at the group
and then drove away at speed to the
safety as you planned it of Thomas
waring's home
I'm satisfied that you asked Waring to
look after the gun and that you asked
him to help to destroy the stolen
Mercedes six days later
as the jury have found you wearing knew
that Chapman had carried out the
shooting and that he had murdered Ellie
Edwards when you agreed to help in the
disposing of the car
you also knew that the police wanted to
arrest Chapman
the murder of Ellie Edwards has caused
profound and permanent grief to her
family
and a great shock to the entire
community
she was a very much loved young woman in
her prime killed by you Chapman when you
were prepared to kill anyone in your
determination for gang Revenge
this court has heard exceptionally
moving statements from Ellie Edwards
family by her father her brother her
grandmother
and they will never be able to come to
terms with what happened to Ali
the seriousness of this offense of
murder count one is very substantially
aggravated by the following evidence
the choice of weapon which was
exceptionally dangerous
the location of the offense with many
people present on Christmas Eve
the background of criminal gang violence
the substantial preparation and
premeditation
the removal or destruction of important
evidence including the car phones and
clothing as well as the washing of
clothes
the fact you were the subject of
criminal gang injunctions and as you
told the jury you were dealing in class
A drugs
apart from your age at the time of
offending being 22 you're now 23. there
is no significant mitigation
whilst young age can be significant in
the circumstances of your offending
Chapman it carries little weight
I'm a sentence you Connor Chapman not
just for this very serious offense of
murder
but also for the two offenses of
attempted murder counts two and three
two offenses of wounding with intent to
cause Grievous bodily harm counts four
and five
an assault occasionally actual bodily
harm count six
and possessing firearm together with
possessing ammunition both with intent
to endanger life count to seven and
eight
I must also sent it sue for an offensive
handling stolen goods which concerns the
stolen Mercedes A-Class
for reasons it will become clear I will
pass concurrent sentences on all of
these offenses
but the seriousness of all your
offending will be reflected in the
sentence I impose on count one murder
the sentence of murder is imprisonment
for life
I have to decide
what whether that should be a whole life
or a minimum term which you'll have to
serve
the difference is whether you're
offending is so exceptionally serious in
the context of the gravest of murder
offenses
that you should serve the whole of your
life in custody rather than a very long
term
whilst I'm sure that there are some who
would readily consider that a whole life
term should be imposed
I have concluded that your offending is
on the cusp between a whole life and a
very long minimum term
and in the circumstances I cannot
conclude that a whole life term as a
sentence of Last Resort for the very
gravis of murders must be imposed
the starting point in fixing the minimum
term which is the period that you must
serve in custody before you might seek
to be released is 30 years on count one
I must increase that term
firstly to reflect the factors which
increase its seriousness
and secondly to reflect the other
offenses including two offenses of
attempted murder
I take into account also to The Limited
extent that it provides any mitigation
your age
accordingly I increase the minimum term
to firstly 36 years and secondly up to
48 years which reflects your total
offending
so that I send it's understood by you
Connor Chapman as well as those who are
observing
it means that you will have to serve 48
years in custody before you could apply
for release
and if you're ever released and
considering your dangerousness that
might never happen you will be on
license for the rest of your life and
subject to recall to prison if you've
breach the terms of that license
I must also impose the sentences to be
served at the same time as your sentence
on count one
on counts two and three being for
attempted murder
I'm satisfied that each of those
offenses require separate sentences of
imprisonment for life under Section 285
of the sentencing act 2020
there for a schedule 19 offense and you
are a dangerous offender given the
circumstances of these attempted murder
offenses and the murder of Ellie Edwards
they fall within category A2 under the
guideline with a starting point of 30
years which I increase on each to 33
years to reflect the aggravating factors
I have identified in count one
there is little by way of mitigation I
must then fix a minimum term which I set
at 22 years
accordingly the sentences for counts two
and three
are concurrent sentences of imprisonment
for life with a minimum term of 22 years
this means that you'll have to serve
three life sentences concurrently
on counts four and five section 18
wounding with intent they fall within
category A3 of the guideline
adjusting the starting point to reflect
aggravating and mitigating factors I
impose seven years imprisonment
concurrently
on count 6 section 47 assault which
Falls within category A3 I impose 18
months concurrently
on count seven and eight offenses of
possessing a firearm under possessing
its ammunition both being category 1A
offenses under the guideline I imposed
15 years imprisonment concurrently with
each other and all other sentences
handling stolen goods I imposed three
years imprisonment concurrently as a
category 2A offense
Connor Chapman stand up
I sent it to you as follows on count 1
to imprisonment for life with a minimum
term to serve in custody of 48 years
less 176 days served on remand
on counts two and three concurrent
sentences of imprisonment for life under
Section 285 the sentencing act 2020 with
a minimum term of 22 years
on counts four and five concurrent
sentences of seven years imprisonment
on count six a concurrent sentence of 18
months imprisonment
on count 7 and 8 7 and 8 a concurrent
sentence of 15 years
and for the offense of handling stolen
goods a concurrent sentence of three
years imprisonment he can go down
well let's uh leave Liverpool Crown
Court there where we were hearing the
judges says sentencing of Connor Chapman
for the murder of Ellie Edwards that
took place on Christmas Eve of last a
year uh the sentencing from the judge
was three life sentences to be served
concurrently with a minimum term of 48
years before Connor Chapman can apply
for release uh he will if he does ever
get released be on license for the rest
of his life uh Connor Chapman was
uh
being sentenced for eight different
accounts we are now going to take you
back to Liverpool Crown Court where corn
attachments uh accomplished is being
sentenced a short time after the
shooting
you agreed to look after the submachine
gun until it was later taken away as
undoubtedly it was and has not been
recovered by the police
that firearm was a prohibited firearm
because of its rapid fire facility and
was a type 1 firearm under the guideline
I accept that this offense Falls within
category 3A
and that the starting point for sentence
is six years with a statutory minimum
sentence of five years custody I see no
reason to avoid that minimum term
your previous convictions do not
significantly aggravate the offense
seriousness
and taking into account your age
therefore I reduce the sentence to five
years from the starting point in respect
of count nine
for the offense of assisting an offender
count 10 I'm satisfied that the
offending by Chapman was very grave
which you knew
I'm also satisfied that your assistance
was important
and that it significantly damaged the
interests of Justice because it was the
car used to carry out the shooting
accordingly your culpability was high
and the harm caused was at least medium
set against maximum sentence of 10 years
under the criminal law Act 1967.
there is no sentence guideline for this
offense
but the appropriate sentence before
taking into account your age is six
years which I reduced to five years for
your youth
and it's necessary for your offenses to
be served consecutively that's to say
one after the other
because they're clear and separate acts
one to possess the firearm and the other
to help to destroy the car
however I will reduce your total
sentence under the totality principle to
nine years
I impose concurrent sentence of 12-month
custody of the offense under Section 49
having taken into account your late
guilty plea
stand up Thomas Waring
I sent it to you to five years custody
on count nine and four years custody on
count 10 to be served consecutively a
total sentence of nine years
I impose a concurrent sentence of 12
months for the section 49 offense you
will serve half of that sentence less 92
days on remand you can go down
all right well we heard there from
Liverpool Crown Court the sentencing uh
just now of Thomas Waring the accomplice
of Conor Chapman who was found uh who
was sentenced just now for the murder of
Ellie Edwards uh Thomas wearing it there
we heard sentenced to nine years in
custody that was 10 years uh with one
with 12 months removed from it for his
youth uh Connor Chapman who you can see
on your screen now was sentenced to
three life sentences concurrently that
means that he will spend 48 years in
prison before he can apply for a release
it's a life sentence with a 48-year
minimum turn term if he is released he
will spend the rest of his life on
license which means that he could be
recalled to prison at any time well we
heard there her from the judge in his
remarks that corner Chapman uh he deemed
a highly dangerous man who had carefully
planned the murder of what he thought
was to gang at Rivals but with no
thought for the people who would have
been at the pub on Christmas Eve of last
year uh the judge went through how
Connor Chapman spent days removing and
destroying evidence after the event he
did give the context of this shooting
with a submachine a gun the context
being gang rivalry between two Estates
in the merseyside area Chapman belonging
to the woodchurch gang the woodchurch
estate gang and this being an attempted
Revenge killing on two gang members from
the Ford estate the context the backdrop
of this in merseyside shootings
throughout 2021 and 2022 and the judge
painted a picture of a community that
was already living in fear at 11 52 the
judge said Connor Chapman rushed forward
opened fire there was a group of six
people outside the pub that was on the
Wirral there the lighthouse Inn in
wallasey he opened fire early Edwards
was killed instantly
others were injured
the judge said that Connor Chapman was
the subject of gang injunctions that
he'd already said that he dealt in drugs
he was 22 years at the time of the
offense but that his youth not enough to
be taken into account and to reduce the
sentences Governor Chapman was there uh
for eight he was being sentenced for
eight uh counts first of course the
conviction of Ellie edwards's murder but
seven other accounts those other counts
two counts of attempted murder two
counts of wounding with a intent to
cause Grievous broadly harm and one
count of assault occasioning actual
bodily harm as well as possession of a
scorpion submachine gun with intent to
endanger life and possession of
ammunition with intent to endanger life
so as we heard there the judge saying
that the killer of Ellie Edwards will
spend 48 years in prison before he can
apply for any sorts of release he will
spend the rest of his life even if he
does get released on a license his
accomplice Thomas wearing uh who uh
whose house Chapman fled to after the
shooting and who helped uh Chapman to
destroy the burnt the Mercedes that he'd
used to flee the scene after the killing
was sentenced to nine years in total for
the possession of a prohibited firearm
and for assisting and uh assisting an
offender those two sentences five years
each to be served consecutively rather
than concurrently and with 12 months
removed for his youth his young age
to remind you uh of course this was a
murder that took place uh Christmas Eve
of last year Ellie Edwards a beautician
26 years old who'd been on a night out
on that Christmas Eve in the lighthouse
in in Wars the on the Wirral uh she had
been with uh friends and of course she
never returned from that night out so we
heard earlier a victim impact statement
from her father where he spoke about the
Christmases that he will never have the
celebrations that he will never have the
fact that Christmas Eve will not be
something that his family celebrates
ever again the effect on the Family's
mental health that the death of his
daughter has had and it was telling that
the mother of Ellie Edwards did not
appear in a court today to listen to
that sentencing of her daughter's
murderer
um murder of course that was in a sense
one could call it a byproduct of gang
Warfare uh well Sky's correspondence
Rasheed has been at Liverpool Crown
Court this afternoon uh and enzyme I've
just tell us what it was like in court
today
um incredibly emotional uh particularly
when you start with those Victim Impact
statements spread out by the lawyers on
behalf of the family
but also when Connor Chapman was given
his minimum sentence of 48 years that's
how long he will spend Behind Bars
before he can apply to be released 48
years was probably one of the largest
sentences you can get in a whole life
term he was of course yesterday found
guilty for the murder of Ellie Edwards
amongst other counts as well and for
that murder charge he has been given a
total of 48 years minimum in prison a 23
year old man he will be
71 when he can apply to be released from
prison we go back and look at this case
this was a brutal murder it was a
shooting that happened just 10 minutes
before Christmas day outside what was an
incredibly busy Pub on Christmas Eve it
was packed with people young people the
age of Ellie Edwards who was just 26
years old she had come out into the Beer
Garden
for a smoke and it was her who took two
bullets to the back of the head which
were completely unsurvivable there were
five other men injured that night as
well and the gunman Connor Chapman had
arrived in wallasey three hours before
at around nine o'clock in the evening he
essentially did a wrecking of the area
and then about 55 minutes
before he fired his gun
um
he waited in a car parking spot to look
for his two Targets those who were
essentially criminal gang members of the
opposite estate he was looking out for
Kieran selkeld and Jake Duffy and they
were his intended target he did manage
to seriously injure them however there
was nothing that was stopping him firing
12 rounds into a crowd of people and it
was Ellie Edwards who got into in the
way he was a wholly innocent bystander
and took two bullets to the back of the
head it would just give you a bit of
information of of what was happening
inside Court when those
um
those verdicts the the sentencing was
given out by the judge uh when he said
it was 48 years reflects your total
offending Tim Edwards Ellie edwards's
father looked directly at Connor Chapman
and said goodbye to him uh when those uh
sentences were were read out
um there was also cheers from the public
Gallery as well as you can imagine the
family who've been sat through three and
a half weeks of this trial reliving CCTV
footage reliving moments leading up to
Ellie edwards's death they were
incredibly happy but throughout the
whole time that this sentencing was
going on through the victim impact
statements there was a lot of Tears
inside Court a lot of tissues used
because some of those impact statements
were incredibly heartbreaking one from
Tim Edwards Ellie Edwards his father one
from her older brother and one from her
grandma as as well and all the time Tim
Edwards looking directly at Connor
Chapman trying to make eye contact with
the man that murdered his daughter and
if I read you if you don't mind some of
the the notes from those Victim Impact
statements Tim Edwards saying
um that Ellie was the most beautiful the
most kind the most caring person you
could ever ask for he spoke about how
the events of Christmas Eve has impacted
the family in a whole number of ways he
says the feeling of hopelessness he
can't put that into words he said this
has impacted him and his his wife Gainer
for the rest of their lives we are
expecting shortly for the family to come
out the police as well merseyside police
to say a few words he said that I'll do
my very best to make sure her name Ellie
Marlene Edwards is never forgotten he
said Christmas will never be celebrated
by my myself gone is the time of all of
us being together because we will never
all be together Connor Edwards Ellie's
brother also saying that we loved each
other growing up as teenagers we were
born into a big loving family which had
so many lovely memories and he spoke
about the moment he found out that it
was his sister who was shot dead at the
Lighthouse Inn on Christmas Eve he said
I felt numb and traumatized the days
that followed were horrific visiting my
sister lying in the mortaries seeing a
patch above her right eye I will never
forget that picture we never missed a
Christmas together the fact that this
happened at that time is utterly
horrendous he says we've lost everything
we have to carry on as best as we can I
love you and I'll miss you and I'll
cherish the 26 years we had together and
a quick note as well from Ellie's
Grandma who Ellie would often call her
her Queen her grandma would call her her
princess she said if I were to Die
Tomorrow the current override the cause
of death died of a broken heart I miss
my princess so much it was then the
defense gave their mitigations very very
little mitigation it has to be said
there wasn't
um much much support from the defense
they said that their biggest mitigation
was the fact that Connor Chapman was
carried out his attack he's 23 now and
so a whole life forward I mean he would
be a very very old man
when he is released from prison the
judge then summed up saying that your
intention was to murder that night he
said that he is satisfied that you're a
highly dangerous man we've all watched
the CCTV and sound recording of that
shooting you had no thought at all of no
one else at least all to innocent people
he looked directly at Connor Chapman and
said you didn't care Connor Chapman was
then given a 48 year sentence well a
whole life sentence with a minimum of 48
years by the judge I think we can see
merseyside police shortly coming out
along with the family as well we'll hear
exactly what it is that they've got to
say very shortly
um also Thomas Waring his co-defendant
was um sentenced today Thomas Waring
with found guilty of two charges
yesterday that was possessing a firearm
the god one that Connor Chapman used
that night was in Thomas waring's house
after the shooting and also Thomas
Waring had helped Connor Chapman burn
out the A-Class Mercedes a stolen car
that was used that evening to carry out
his attack so Thomas Waring also
sentenced um this evening if I just go
this afternoon if I just go through the
list of what it was specifically that
Connor Chapman received from the judge
this afternoon on count one of murder it
was a minimum of 48 years on count two
and three these were concurrent life
sentences with a minimum of 23 years and
these were attempted murder on those two
intended targets Jake Duffy and Kieran
selkeld there were also other counts in
this trial as well and for that he has
received other concurrent
sentences but of course it is that big
one and
and I think from memory one of the
largest
sentences for murder in this country of
course many remember what happened in
this city
um also last year to a little girl
Olivia Pratt Corbell who was shot
by Thomas Cashman he received a sentence
of 42 years the judge has gone six years
above that for this sentence Connor
Chapman receiving a minimum sentence of
48 years as I said we are expecting
Ellie Edwards is incredibly emotional
but also very happy family now to come
out and say a few words we're also
expecting to hear from the senior
investigating officer I'm just looking
over at the police yes we'll hear from
the senior investigating officer in this
case as well a case which brought a lot
of CCTV to the table and it was that
that played a crucial role throughout
this trial CCTV of not only the moment
of the shooting where Connor Chapman
fire 12 bullets into the crowd of people
at the pub but also CCTV of the man
ruffling his long hair dropping the
Scorpion machine gun as he walked to his
friend's house CCTV and DNA recovered as
well of uh red gloves that he wore
whilst he carried out his attack covered
in Connor Chapman's DNA of bullet casing
which was also covered in his DNA found
at the murder scene essentially for the
jury who came back within three hours
yesterday the evidence was incredibly
overwhelming to convict Connor Chapman
of murder but that is the news from
Liverpool Crown Court
there in Wimbledon we're going to take
you back to Liverpool Crown Court with a
family of Ellie Edwards are about to
speak after the sentencing of her
murderer
okay
Connor Chapman is to Dave in jailed for
life for the senseless and tragic murder
of Ellie Edwards in will on Christmas
Eve last year
Ellie was a young woman with her whole
life ahead of her who was simply
enjoying a night out in a corporate with
a family and friends
cowardly actions of Chapman on that
night firing Abby's intended targets
whilst they were stood outside in a
crowd shows the arrogance and contempt
that he had for everybody else
as a result of his Reckless actions
Ellie had a life tragically cut short
her family and friends and everyone who
knew her have been left devastated by
their loss
today Chapman is behind bars where he
rightly belongs
and Worley will now spend a considerable
period of his adult life
he's co-accused Thomas worrying has also
been brought to Justice
no sentence however long can change what
Chapman did but I hope that knowing he
has been brought to Justice and is off
our streets brings some small amount of
comfort
I hope that it serves as a deterrent to
anybody considering picking up or using
a gun
I would like to take this opportunity to
pay a tribute to Ali's family who
throughout the whole investigation and
the trial have remained dignified and
composed despite being forced to relive
the horrific events of Christmas Eve
and I hope that they can now start to
properly grieve their loss
I would like to thank the crown
prosecution service Adam Clark and then
in particular Nigel Powers Queens
Council and Katie Appleton for the
successful prosecution of the case
I would also like to thank all officers
and staff from across all strands of
merseyside police who were involved in
this case from day one the commitment
dedication and hard work has been key to
the investigation and has allowed us to
successfully prosecute Chapman and
whirling and get the justice for Ellie's
family thank you
I'd like to just Echo what Paul said
early
um
the
the amounts of people involved in this
investigation
from day one literally from the minute
it happened has been remarkable and they
did not give up they were Relentless and
and achieving the goal which is to get
Justice for Ellie and catch the Killer
thankfully now he's got 48 years and
hopefully he never sees Christmas again
if I'm lucky enough to still be around
for a long time yeah
I will do my best to make sure he never
comes out jail
and I know there's a lot of people
who've been affected by this and that
includes the whole family of the army
I don't know
it needs to be the only things need to
change and we've made the start with
that and I think the 48 years if you
think of picking up a gun now you should
think twice about it
and I'd like to thank as again there's a
side police the whole family behind me
we've sat here for four weeks
and have to go through this something
that we'll never forget
but it was all done for Ellie and we
achieved that today thank you
well we heard uh there from the father
of Ellie Edwards Tim Edwards before him
uh the detective superintendent to Paul
Grant who was leading the investigation
into the murder of Ellie Edwards are
correspondent since a man Rasheed has
been at Liverpool Crown Court all day
and following uh the sentencing of
Connor Chapman and his accomplice Thomas
Waring over the murder of Ellie Edwards
into Mom I hope you can hear me uh now
but
we were of course waiting to hear from
Ellie Edward's father he's been
outspoken over the last 24 hours and
what we heard there
was perhaps I guess a look towards the
future now that things might be able to
change and this a community reeling uh
from the shock uh of Ellie's death but
also hoping that things in merseyside
might change
yeah it was a it was a much different
tone from Tim Edwards uh from what we've
seen um particularly yesterday when
Connor Chapman was found guilty of the
murder of his daughter he came out he
said that he hopes he rots in hell he
hopes that the two of them never see a
single Christmas once again he hopes uh
that Connor Chapman is never ever
released from prison today a bit more
subdued I would say and you're right
looking towards the future reminding
other criminals
um not just here in Liverpool on
merseyside but beyond as well that if
you decide to carry out such crimes that
is potentially the time you could serve
a minimum of 48 years is what Connor
Chapman has received today for his uh
murder of Ellie Edwards for the
attempted murders of other two others as
well those intended targets that he
tried to kill that night on Christmas
Eve 10 minutes just before Christmas day
in what was a very very busy a pact Pub
the lighthouse Inn in wallasey it was
busy with people who were obviously
celebrating during the festive period
just enjoying themselves and then a
group of people which included Ellie
Edwards came out into the beer garden
just four minutes before Connor Chapman
who'd been laying in weight for around
55 minutes with a clear unobstructed
view of the front entrance creeped up to
the building and fired 12 bullets into
that crowd what police called was
indiscriminately and two of those
bullets ended up in the back of Ellie
edwards's head but just hearing then
from merseyside police as well who have
carried out this whole investigation
they've clearly said that they are
hoping this case is a deterrent to
criminals in the future they hope that
this sentence sets a precedent for gun
crime going forward in this region last
year there were five fatal shootings
across merseyside this being the last
one on Christmas Eve and merseyside
police have tried to work hard to ensure
that they are working on gun crime in
this region and what they do hope is
that Ellie edwards's story Ellie Edwards
is sacrifice essentially is something
that can be taken forward and criminals
will make sure that they think twice
before pulling a trigger but just a note
on her father inside Court
he was incredibly celebratory when
Connor Chapman was given that 48-year
sentence he'd actually waved goodbye to
Connor Chapman and said the words
goodbye as he was handed that sentence
and then when the judge told Connor
Chapman that he could go down there were
shouts of scumbag from the gallery there
were shouts of goodbye lad rat as well
screamed from the public Gallery along
with cheers from many friends and family
of Ellie Edwards of course they have had
to sit through not just the last six
months since her passing but the three
and a half weeks to four weeks of this
trial reliving all that evidence which
has actually been played out quite
clearly in front of their eyes hearing
those 12 gunshots that were fired into
the crowd of people seeing Connor
Chapman give evidence during this trial
as well and lying about what he did that
night it would have been been incredibly
difficult for that family but now there
is a huge sigh of relief not just after
yesterday because he was convicted for
murder but today he will be at least 71
years old before the man who was
responsible for the murder of 26 year
old Ellie Edwards will be released
there's no doubt that this family will
be breathing a huge sigh of relief today
merseyside police as well and Connor
Chapman will be spending a very very
long time behind bars for his murder of
the 26 year old beautician on Christmas
Eve last year yeah absolutely handsome
as you said there Connor Chapman will be
in his 70s before he even gets a chance
of release from prison it's interesting
that you were talking about the role of
Tim Edwards and he has taken whereas we
haven't seen Gainer Ellie's mum in court
we have seen and heard a lot of Tim
Edwards he seems to have gone through a
lot a journey himself and sort of been
to an extent they're happy to play that
out in in a public setting I just wonder
what you think about whether this is
something he will take up in the future
perhaps as you know make him make it his
cause perhaps against gun and gang
violence in his community in merseyside
look you know I've been speaking to Tim
um almost since day one of uh this whole
case
um we met a couple of days after uh it
was revealed that it was his daughter
who who was killed on Christmas Eve um
we interviewed him in in early January
as well he said at that time he would
make it his commitment to make sure that
Ellie's name does not
uh go down and forgotten he will make
sure that it is her name that is taken
forward to help tackle these kind of
issues particularly across merseyside
um but you're right Ellie's mum hasn't
really been seen she was seen at the
funeral of Ellie Edwards but she hasn't
really spoken out and actually there
were some words written by her that were
read out inside the court she said that
I want to know why you have done this
speaking directly to Connor Chapman what
drove you to do this to my daughter she
asked she also said since she's been
gone I've never been the same I still
expect her to come home since she's gone
my health has deteriorated she added
that we can't ask for more of our
children they've all turned out well and
have done us proud Ellie was not afraid
of a challenge she said just as her life
was cut short she was reaching her Peak
and the happiest I'd ever seen her she
was positive about the future so there
were some were
from Ellie edwards's mom in a victim
impact statement that were read out by
the the um the prosecution lawyer Nigel
Powers KC but those words from her
brother as well words from her father
words from her grandmother were
incredibly emotional that Court was
packed with Ellie's family and friends
and and there were tears throughout the
whole time those Victim Impact
statements were being read as you can
imagine as well her brother really
really poignant in saying that he
remembers just messaging Ellie just a
couple of hours before she was at the
lighthouse in saying that what's the
plan for tomorrow what's the plan for
Christmas Day because she was supposed
to cook Christmas dinner usually her dad
Cooks but it was her turn that year to
cook Christmas dinner he said that we
loved each other so much growing up as
teenagers we loved each other and we
were always on the same path he spoke
about as well how
he saw her lying in the mortuary when he
found out that he was Ellie Edwards who
had sadly been murdered on Christmas Eve
he said he felt numb he said he
remembers looking at her and seeing
um the patches above her right eye
clearly where
um the bullets had been and he says
that's a memory that he will simply
never ever forget he said we've lost
everything and we carry on as best as we
can and he said directly to Ellie
Edwards I love you I miss you and I'll
cherish the 26 years we had together
what's important to know Connor Chapman
was sat right there he came to court he
came to court to listen to his sentence
and he listened to those Victim Impact
statements but there was nothing from
him in terms of remorse he kept a very
simple deadpan face there was no remorse
there was no acknowledgment of regret
for what he had done and the whole time
Tim Edwards Ellie's father was looking
directly at him which he has done
throughout this trial particularly when
the jury was shown the CCTV of the
moment Connor Chapman pulled the trigger
and fired those 12 shots into a crowd of
people Tim Edwards looking directly at
the man who was responsible for
murdering his daughter he told me that
he was looking to see if there was any
remorse if there was any regret from
this man and he said that this simply
wasn't but clearly a huge sentence one
of the largest given for murder in this
country Connor Chapman a 23 year old man
has today been given a life sentence and
he will have to serve a minimum of 48
years for murdering Ellie Edwards on
Christmas Eve last year
and Instagram if for those people who
are joining us now here on Sky News just
to remind you that we are hearing uh
there of the sentencing of uh Connor
Chapman for the murder of Ellie Edwards
on Christmas Eve of last year in uh
merseyside uh he will serve three life
sentences concurrently and it he will
have a minimum term of 48 years his
accomplice Thomas Waring uh will spend
at least nine uh will uh spend nine
years in uh prison uh in response uh to
the sentencing that took place within
the last hour or so we heard from the
detective superintendent uh from
merseyside police who was in charge of
that investigation Paul grounds let's
have a listen to what he said
Connor Chapman is today been jailed for
life for the senseless and tragic murder
of Ellie Edwards in will on Christmas
Eve last year
Ellie was a young woman with her whole
life ahead of her who was simply
enjoying a night out in a corporate with
her family and friends
the Cowardly actions of Chapman on that
night firing Abby's intended targets
whilst they were stood outside in a
crowd shows the arrogance and contempt
that he had for everybody else
as a result of his Reckless actions
Ellie had a life tragically cut short
her family and friends and everyone who
knew her have been left devastated by
their loss
today Chapman is behind bars where he
rightly belongs
and Willie will now spend a considerable
period of his adult life
he's co-accused Thomas worrying has also
been brought to Justice
no sentence however long can change what
Chapman did but I hope that knowing he
has been brought to Justice and is off
our streets brings some small amount of
comfort
I hope that it serves as a deterrent to
anybody considering picking up or using
a gun
I would like to take this opportunity to
pay a tribute to Ali's family who
throughout the whole investigation and
the trial have remained dignified and
composed despite being forced to relive
the horrific events of Christmas Eve
and I hope that they can now start to
properly grieve their loss
I would like to thank the crown
prosecution service Adam Clark and then
in particular Nigel powerskins Council
and Katie Appleton for the successful
prosecution of the case
I would also like to thank all officers
and staff from across all strands of
merseyside police who were involved in
this case from day one the commitment
dedication and hard work has been key to
the investigation and has allowed us to
successfully prosecute Chapman and
wording and get the justice for Ellie's
family thank you
I'd like to just Echo what Paul said
early
um
the
the amounts of people involved in this
investigation
from day one literally from the minute
it happened has been remarkable and they
did not give up they were Relentless and
and achieving the goal which is to get
Justice for Ellie and catch the Killer
thankfully now he's got 48 years and
hopefully he never sees Christmas again
if I'm lucky enough to still be around
for a long time yeah
I will do my best to make sure he never
comes out Joe
and
I know there's a lot of people who've
been affected by this and that includes
the whole family of the army
I don't know
it needs to be if things need to change
and we've made the start with that and I
think for 48 years
if you think of picking up a gun now you
should think twice about it
and I'd like to thank as again a very
sad police the whole family behind me
we've sat here for four weeks
and have to go through this something
that we'll never forget
but it was all done for Ellie and we
achieved that today thank you
thank you
Tim Edwards the father of Ellie Edwards
speaking there in response to the
sentencing of Ellie edwards's murderer
for uh three life sentences uh serving
at least 48 years in uh prison we have
had a uh a reaction to that sentencing
from the local MP Angela Eagle labor MP
for wallacy she says this afternoon
justice has been served my thoughts
continue to be with Ellie Edwards family
and loved ones I hope today will bring
them some comfort though it's nothing
compared to the hell they've experienced
since her death we cannot allow Gangland
violence and cowardly cold-blooded
murder to Prevail on the will it is
vital our community is protected from
violence and that those who perpetrate
such crimes face the consequences of
their life-destroying behavior as Connor
Chapman has that there the tweet from
local MP Angela Eagle let's go straight
back to Instagram Rasheed who's at
Liverpool Crown course and we heard that
from Angela Eagle there this this notion
which we've had again and from from
Eddie edwards's father and from the
superintendent deterrence that hopefully
this 48 year or more than 48 years as uh
in prison will act as a deterrent for
those in merseyside looking uh to pick
up a gun but of course this isn't the
first uh incidental death from gang
violence in the region do you think it
is going to be enough of a of a
deterrent
I think that really is the big question
merseyside police will certainly hope
that it is but they thought that the
killing of Rhys Jones back in uh the
early 2000s 2007 I think it was that
um they they were hoping that that would
set a precedent for gang violence across
this region it didn't we saw last year
five uh deaths five murders from uh
gunshot wounds
um of course as most of us remember
nine-year-old Olivia Pratt Corbell who
was killed by Thomas Cashman Thomas
Cashman was given a sentence of 42 years
but today
um and I think quite surprisingly as
well the judge went above that 48 years
he said I'm satisfied you're a hugely
dangerous man we've all watched the CCTV
and the sound recording of that shooting
you had no thought of anyone else
all that at least innocent people you
simply did not care Connor Chapman given
a whole life sentence with a minimum of
48 years for the murder of Ellie Edwards
yeah and certainly questions for the
community questions for policing
questions culturally as to how to solve
that epidemic of gang Warfare in uh
merseyside after the sentencing of the
murderer of Ellie edwards's killer to
life in prison with at least 48 years to
be served in prison we'll be back after
the break